let's now turn to Nintendo's newest game
Pokemon go because it's sweeping the
nation
this revolutionary smartphone app has
soared to the top of download charts a
Nintendo stock has skyrocketed joining
us now is Bloomberg News Selena Wong
Selena so let's start with the basics
for people that have still to download
the app how does this work yeah how
viral this game has gotten is pretty
insane and if you walk around New York
you're going to see multitudes of people
running around playing this game but how
it works is that it's a location-based
apps so you can also think almost think
of it as a fantasy Google Maps you walk
around and you're going to be trying to
find Pokemon characters overlaid over
the real world and you're gonna try to
catch these Pokemon characters and
Selena we were showing earlier the ad
are for Nintendo and how its soaring
today at more than 30% in Japan of
course Nintendo's shares rallied by the
twenty five percent limit so you have
the knee-jerk reaction but what does
this really mean for the company down
the road once the fever dies off a
little bit it's been a really tough time
for Nintendo they're seen as kind of not
being able to keep up with the changes
in the gaming industry as their console
sales have slowed as people are moving
towards these mobile gaming apps but now
investors are seeing that this is really
just the tip of the IP iceberg of
Nintendo this Pokemon brand has such
pull if they're able to make more hits
like this by capitalizing on their
franchises I mean the potential is
enormous and that's why we're seeing
these insane skyrockets in its stock
price so we're calling this app just a
our augmented reality which is a
combination of a game and also the real
world what does this mean for the trend
in this a new innovation of AR and also
for the rest of the gaming industry
right so AR is basically just overlaying
digital images over the existing real
world and I think this is a huge
harbinger for the future of AR we
shouldn't say that this is a watershed
moment but it is a big deal because this
is a very simple technology it's not the
complicated AR headsets that companies
like microsoft's hololens are trying to
do but in a way it's a gateway
for people to get familiar with what
mented reality is and what the potential
for it is so I wouldn't be surprised if
we see more mobile game developers
trying to use location-based or
different types of more simple AR into
their own games but the popular Celina
sorry Scarlett go ahead no no I was
gonna ask about the companies behind
this because obviously a Nintendo wins
big from this but who are the names
involved in in coming up with this
augmented reality app I mean what is
their linkage to Silicon Valley
definitely I think we need to not forget
about me antic they are the actual
developer of this game so the founder of
neon tech actually came from Google it
used to be a Google startup and he was
part of Google Maps so a lot of the hard
technology behind this game comes from
me antic and they had a previous game
called ingress that did almost the same
thing as Pokemon go but they really
needed Nintendo in that Pokemon game to
have this reach mass appeal beyond the
super nerdy hardcore gaming community